first of all let's take a look at  something else uh opening ceremonies  that took place yesterday it was very  nice by the way peter it was it was  very very nicely organized as usual  the the opening ceremonies here are  incredibly on point in that  they are  just as long as they need to be exactly  it was all about for  pulling them drawing the numbers but it  really was more like  hey everybody where you've been what  you've been up to how's it going  uh i thought that jan was actually  entertaining too it was answers  that christian had christian was the  master of ceremonies  and  rex welcomed everybody as he always does  in his own  initial world fashion  yeah and the  there you see the the drawing of lots  where players had to choose a very  beautiful book as their number for the  rapid and blitz and then a fridge magnet  as their number in the uh  sorry in first in the in the rapid  portion of